stunning and dramatic visuals out of
London as the royal family marches
behind the late Monarch and the people
pay their final respects to the queen
welcome to Entertainment Tonight yes
watching that you just can't help but
flash back to when William and Harry
were walking behind the coffin of their
mother Princess Diana in front of the
world our Katie nickel is in London with
the latest on the brothers in mourning
[Music]
for me the thing I remember the most was
the sound of the horses who's going
along the lung pain it was like I was
outside of my body I'm just walking
along doing what was expected of me
25 years later both brothers United
again in grief William and Harry walking
in lockstep behind another coffin Harry
remaining stoic amid the kind of public
mourning that triggered him as a child
you get in your head about it and then
you're just like everybody's looking at
me inside Westminster Hall Harry was
seen wiping his eyes Megan by his side
The Duchess was emotional in the car as
they left together and there was this
supportive moment inside Megan stayed
close to Harry clutching his hand while
William and Kate followed Royal protocol
walking with a space between them now
the question is is Megan's prominent
appearance today evidence of a receding
Royal Rift I want also to express my
love for Harry and Megan Her Majesty the
queen approved all of the plans for her
service with Charles in advance neither
Megan nor Kate walked the route along
with the family Princess Anne was the
only female allowed which is actually a
sign of how the late Queen has moved
things forward for women and another
thing of Interest the arrivals Camilla
and Kate arrived together at Westminster
Hall Megan followed in the next car
along with Edward's wife Sophie Megan
being in the car with Sophie shows that
King Charles is doing everything he can
to make sure that the sussexes have been
a part of this historic and important
moment
all this as newly crowned King Charles
III appeared to crack under extreme
pressure five days after losing his
mother the 73 year old Monarch went
viral over his frustration with a pen
foreign
as for his mother's will that won't be
made public but we are learning more
about William's massive inheritance he
gets ownership of royal properties
including the Sandringham estate and
Balmoral Castle estimated worth over 1
billion dollars and a hefty yearly
salary 25 million dollars to be precise
William is no longer reliant on the bank
of dad he is now financially independent
for himself Kate and of course their
children
foreign